President Trump has announced a new
group to help reopen the country we're
also setting up a Council of very very
great doctors and businesspeople I call
it the opening our country task force or
opening our country Council joining us
now someone who has experience with
White House counsel's and Task Force
shall we say Mack McLarty former chief
of staff to President Clinton chairman
of the McClarty group is well good to
see you sir appreciate it does this make
sense to you or too early no I think
it's about right Leland I think the
president along with the governors and
mayors and other leaders in our country
both from the public and private sector
first need to meet the moment which was
the crisis of the pandemic to really
seriously address the health issues I
think they had made every effort to do
that with dr. Fauci dr. Burks others to
flatten that curve and for the hospitals
not to get overrun and with all of our
hearts and admiration go out for the
first responders including doctors
nurses but now I think it is time to
look past meeting the moment not to take
our eye off the ball to be very clear
we've still got work to do
to make sure that this environment is
safe and that we save as many lives as
we can from this very barrel at epidemic
but it is time to look forward how we
can get this economy reopen because
that's about renewing and building lives
as well and how to do that so I think
the precious timing is about right and
other governors across the country are
taking some lesson there we heard from
the governor of Oklahoma a little bit
earlier who did talk about that in terms
of how exactly to reopen things like
starting with elective surgeries and
then restaurants at 50% etc as we look
at the weekly job numbers week ending
April for six point six million
unemployment claims six point nine
million the week before three point
three million the week before that
sixteen point seven eight million ten
percent of the workforce without a job
in three weeks you think it's fair to
say
that no president has ever faced
something quite like this before I think
this situation is unprecedented I don't
think there's a question about that it's
whiplash the economy was moving forward
at a rapid pace in terms of growth jobs
and even wage increases and all of a
sudden the pending me yet and the
economy was shuttered shuttered and you
can just look at the front pages of
newspapers and look at those
unemployment claims which reflect your
10% so this is unprecedented it's
unsettling and it's challenging but I
think we can can rise to meet the a you
have a unique perspective in this having
served at both the highest levels in
government that had also been highly
successful in business both before and
after your time in government where is
the intersection that government can
actually help when it comes to reopening
the country and what does government
need to stay out of to allow American
business and American entrepreneurs to
do and be their best that's the right
question my view I think the government
again both a federal and state and local
level have to step forward to be
supportive on the health part I think
that's number one there obviously has to
be tremendous response from at the local
level and from the private sector as
well from from the health care providers
first responders I think from a business
standpoint certainly a clear pathway
ahead to the extent they can be started
and noted that's what the government can
do is give a framework here and support
which I think the package that the
Congress passed following the
administration's lead is part of that
all right
Mack McLarty of the Clinton
administration and now of the McClarty
group we appreciate your time sir all
the best to you and stay safe the coming
week sir